-Performing "Lifetime" from his
new album
"AudioLust & HigherLove,"
give it up for SG Lewis!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I've waited for a lifetime ♪
-♪ To tell you I love you ♪
-♪ To tell you I love you now ♪
♪ Sunday night's been and gone ♪
♪ Like a cool breeze ♪
♪ Till Monday morning
comes along ♪
♪ But the weight of the world
can't hold me down ♪
♪ It's mind over matter, baby,
you're the one I found ♪
♪ Playin' on my mind, so I wanna
take the time ♪
♪ To tell you how I feel for
you, you know that ♪
-♪ I've waited for a lifetime ♪
-♪ To tell you I love you ♪
-♪ To tell you I love you now ♪
-♪ Well, maybe I've been
a fool ♪
♪ I was afraid of
what I'd lose ♪
♪ But the weight of the world
can't hold me down ♪
♪ It's mind over matter, baby,
you're the one I found ♪
♪ Playin' on my mind, so I wanna
take the time ♪
♪ To tell you how I feel for
you, you know that ♪
♪ I've waited for a lifetime ♪
♪ To tell you I love you ♪
-♪ I've waited for a lifetime ♪
-♪ To tell you I love you ♪
♪ I've waited for a lifetime ♪
♪ To tell you I love you ♪
-♪ I've waited for a lifetime ♪
-♪ To tell you I love you now ♪
-♪ Ooh, ooh, ooh ♪
[ Applause ]
♪ Ooh, ooh, ooh ♪
♪♪
-♪ I've waited for a lifetime ♪
♪ To tell you I love you ♪
-♪ To tell you I love you ♪
♪ I've waited for a lifetime ♪
♪ To tell you I love you ♪
-♪ I've waited for a lifetime ♪
-♪ To tell you I love you now ♪
-♪ Ooh, ooh, ooh ♪
[ Applause ]
♪ Ooh, ooh, ooh ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]